between vacations and pool parties it's
easy to let health and wellness fall by
the wayside in the summer dietitian
registered dietitian mia finn has tips
on how to stay healthy and hydrated
hey las vegas now summer is all about
fun in the sun but don't let that
distract you from staying healthy and
hydrated today i have four simple summer
wellness tips my first tip is to eat
your water staying hydrated is essential
for energy digestion and more and water
needs increase in the warmer months you
can meet your needs through the
beverages you drink and the foods you
consume namely fruits and vegetables a
nutritious dip like hummus can help
encourage their consumption fresh
cravings hummus is creamy delicious and
comes in a variety of unique flavors
including honey jalapeno and everything
bagel in 10 ounce tubs and larger family
size it's made with a short list of high
quality ingredients including chickpeas
tahini and chilean extra virgin olive
oil use it as a dip for celery cucumber
and bell peppers all vegetables that are
made up of over 90 water
my next summer wellness tip is to choose
beverages with benefits matcha is a
powdered green tea that provides calming
energy and health benefits through its
combination of caffeine antioxidants and
amino acids such as l-theanine freshly
milled ceremonial grade matcha is
uniquely delicious and naturally creamy
without the astringency or bitterness
that can accompany matcha powders that
have been sitting on the shelf river and
stone matchas milled in minneapolis
using the highest quality japanese
matcha leaves on authentic matcha mills
imported from japan and shipped
throughout north america by priority
mail no later than the next day to
ensure maximum freshness find the
samadori matcha at northeast tea house
in minneapolis or online at
riverandstonetea.com
next rethink your summer grilling menu
chilean salmon is a low mercury fish
available fresh and frozen year round
contains a unique package of hard to
find nutrients including vitamin d and
omega-3 fats the applegate naturals do
good dogs available at whole foods in
walmart are made with regeneratively
sourced beef that is 100 natural and
grass-fed in fact they boast the world's
first regenerative sourcing verification
like all their products they contain no
antibiotics ever and are humanely raised
instead of high fat dressings and
condiments flavor your proteins with
nutritious toppings grilled corn pickles
and salsa fresh cravings never cooked or
pasteurized refrigerated salsa from
walmart is made with vine ripened
tomatoes crisp vegetables and zesty
peppers so it tastes homemade finally
support your digestion this summer with
probiotics probiotics are beneficial
bacteria that support digestion and
immune health and are found in foods
like yogurt sauerkraut and tempeh
consider a science-backed probiotic
supplement like trubiotics capsules or
gummies available on amazon which
features select research-backed
probiotics that are designed to
withstand their journey through the body
to land where they're needed in the
gastrointestinal tract so they can
support healthy microbiome diversity and
digestive and immune health i hope you
enjoyed these tips and recipes you can
find everything on my website
nutritionbymia.com
and instagram nutritionbymia where i
also share healthy recipes and nutrition
tips daily